[Music]
for a game that was long in development
as a cooperative horde based shooter the
conspicuous and relatively quick edition
of battle royale in fortnight seemed to
be a mote act on to capitalize on a
trend however it's simple building
system in loose shooting mechanics not
only set it apart from other games built
on the same premise but work extremely
well to make a uniquely chaotic and
surprisingly deep deathmatch everything
about for tonight's presentation admits
a light-hearted nature you start a match
by jumping out of a party bus held up by
balloons that flies across the massive
map weapons ammo and health items litter
the silly name cities all using
alliteration tomato town moisty mire
tilted towers just the name a few even
enemies don't really die there
teleported after getting knocked out but
don't let that first impression fool you
the further you get into a match the
more you see how for tonight's gameplay
elements have to be used in clever and
complex ways unique to fortnight is a
streamlined building system thanks to a
snappy elegant grid-based layout and the
intuitive control scheme getting the
hang of building isn't much of a hurdle
at first glance it's as if the original
save the world mode had its mechanics
haphazardly dropped into the hundred
player last person standing premise but
this is the foundation that makes for a
myriad of tactical possibilities like
improvising a sky-high staircase to
climb a mountain to get to higher ground
or swiftly creating your own cover as
you run across an open field and closing
on opponents literally bridging the gap
between mountains can turn long-range
shootouts into close quarter brawls it's
a dynamic system that always gives you
an opportunity to improvise even when
you think your back is against the wall
for example players will often protect
themselves with structures that act as
makeshift bunkers to undercut that you
can put pressure on them by constructing
your own path into their territory and
these moments the intrinsically
rewarding nature of fortnight's shines
through conflict isn't just about
landing a precise shot or spotting an
enemy first quick wit and improvisation
with the given toolset put you in a
position to create your own path to
success eliminations and victories feel
very much earned especially because a
late game often consists of which
players squad has the best architectural
acumen into ever-changing safe zones
approaches to combat also rely on the
weapons you can scavenge a typical
Arsenal made up of rifles submachine
guns shotguns and pistols have
color-coded tiers to indicate varying
levels of power and rarity each gun has
a sensible use case however traps and
Explosives mix things up a bit this is
another aspect in which fortnight
divergence for many other battle royale
games shooting is fast and loose akin to
an arena shooter mid-range firefights in
close quarters combat feel more like a
fatal dance in and around the structures
plopped into the environment for night
isn't a tactical shooter in the
traditional sense but offers its own
bevy of strategic options to keep
players on their toes enemy engagement
still carries the risk you'd expect from
games of this ilk by nature of having
one life to live per match and the
relatively quick time to kill even after
downing a chug-chug 4 full shield
well-placed shots from a legendary or
epic will make short work of anyone
however the brisk pace at which matches
moved trades unnerving tension for a
higher frequency of action yet as with
any Battle Royale game looting for
resources sits at the core of matches
and eats up much of your time the system
in place for loot and resource gathering
is efficient but it grows tiresome after
consecutive matches as swinging the
pickaxe at trees and houses for
necessary materials grows increasingly
repetitive another area in which 4/9 is
a bit thin is in its map design a
shortcoming that's twofold the sprawling
load map features a variety of cute
thematic areas but there's a feeling
that many of the maps landmarks lexa
fists occation in physical layouts and
in density of loot placement to its
credit the maps of verticality brings
out the best in your construction
abilities but city centers like tomato
town have little to work with when two
squads land in the area a slightly more
intricate town like snobby shores is
sometimes devoid of useful items it'd be
easier to overlook this if you didn't
have to trek across to a nearby town on
foot that's likely to have already been
looted but such is the case
now in just about half a year epic
proved its supporting for tonight
continually with new content those who
have been playing the game are aware of
the limited time modes that put a slight
twist on the standard mode snipers only
an explosives only matches have added a
neat touch but past modes like 50 V 50
and teams of 20 do much more to change
fortnight's pace and open up new ways to
play the game if that's any indication
fortnight could have plenty more to
offer as it evolves further this is a
free to play game so you should be aware
that it heavily relies on
microtransactions to sustain itself a
ten-dollar battle pass opens up a slew
of skins to earn and provides new goals
to work towards it's a reasonable system
and that these objectives reward you
with cosmetic items that visibly pop
within fortnight's bright art style
there's nothing to infringe on how the
game plays thankfully if you wish to
engage in making your pickaxe look like
a toy or Don's seasonal outfits or get
the latest viral dance as an emote you
either have to put in the time to earn
it or shell out money for the game's
in-game currency called V bugs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
while there are several parts in the
games ecosystem for Knights biggest
accomplishment is in how it seamlessly
merges a number of simple mechanics to
create a distinguishable Battle Royale
game what looks to be a straightforward
building system that elite escalates to
an elaborate display of tactical prowess
as the saying goes it's easy to learn
hard to master although a few
shortcomings in the map design
eventually surface and fatigue and
looting can set in fortnight rarely
fails at challenging you in unexpected
ways resulting in something more than
just another typical last person
standing shooter
[Music]